I don't usually make a habit of going to
subreddits that make me absolutely livid
but I just so happened to come across a
subreddit that really tickled my fancy
really caused me to do just jovial with
joy you know one that just like makes
you like gets you right on the butt
cheeks and makes you just feel like ooh
I hate that and that's when I came
across this subreddit now before I get
into the subreddit itself I need to
preface this I'm a big proponent of
tweets their own like if you like
something that's fine if you don't like
something that's also fine if it goes to
an extreme though that's what I start to
have a problem with it so keep that in
mind as we go through the subreddit
appropriately called dog free now dog
free sounds like a wonderful park where
dogs can run and roam and jump and play
all day in the flowers and the grass
pooping peeing all over each other just
having a great time getting disgusting
in the mud oh what a joyous dog free is
a subreddit about people who hate dogs
in summary basically your dog sucks
you are probably not using it for
hunting or farming or as a service
animal it is your living teddy bear your
eating drinking breathing [ __ ]
slobbering loud stinky dirty teddy bear
that you insist others must love because
look at a person don't love dogs
as a place where those of us who do not
love dogs and do not love dog worship
culture can come and freely complain
about what we have to endure against our
will if you can't accept that don't post
here you will not change any of our
minds if you're a dog lover who wants to
participate in a friendly mature and
respectful way without trying to convert
or condemn anyone then feel free to join
the conversation if not please go back
to our or wherever you feel more
comfortable with that being said I'm not
gonna join the conversation but I am
gonna try to have a fair impartial thing
and I'm gonna try to look at what you
got for the memes that you have and not
necessarily to criticize you harshly and
I don't want anybody attacking anybody
on this because like I said before to
each their own I'm only gonna be
critical of things across the line and
just because this video may or may not
be called the world's worst
does not mean I'm making any pretense of
judgment here I'm just a rabid clickbait
er I always the views I get the views
somehow so I'm gonna do whatever it
takes to get the views alright without
further ado I'm gonna try to look at
some of their posts I'm right now at
their top all-time posts which only
dates back to about eight months ago so
this is a relatively new subreddit all
right woke up to this in my Facebook
newsfeed I was surprised by the sanity
dogs are not better than people you were
just extremely antisocial and lack the
empathy it takes to love something that
isn't bred specifically to please you
you started off so great you started off
so good you started off so good with
dogs are not better than people which
I'm fine with
that's a fair statement that is totally
fair you're just extremely antisocial
and lack the empathy it takes to love
something that isn't bred specifically
to please you
now that's see that's the line here
that's jump line your lumping all of dog
ownership into this one weird group
where somehow we're all anti-social
basement dwellers it's that weird logic
where anybody that disagrees with you
must be subhuman the glorious race of
the dog haters up here we're don't like
dog and then the dog lovers down here
just said a cesspool of dog [ __ ] and
look for big slobbered on force to feed
these animals for the rest of eternity
so that's where I have a little bit of a
problem
heroic pit bull swims five miles I see
two blockage
posted by you need a biscuit [ __ ] I
didn't know I didn't know you're so open
about your your pastimes there I I
glanced over it and I kind of got the
impression that this subreddit doesn't
like pit bulls very much which is very
very uncool because pit bulls are so
[ __ ] sweet why is this so true hard
to swallow pills owning a pet does not
make you a mother raising children does
today is not your holiday dog moms
that's fine I get that that's fine
totally legitimate having a dog doesn't
make you a parent me having chica
doesn't make me a parent in any way
shape or form I know that I still love
that dog and I care for that dog but it
is not the same as raising a human
FairPoint
not a hard pill to swallow I get that
entirely I think that this subreddit
really targets a very specific
demographic of dog moms like those that
like my mom my mom is a hundred percent
dog mom my mom loves her dogs she has
four of them Lucy is her princess Lucy
is a [ __ ] huge great pyrenees
that's an awesome dog a little tug II on
the leash but she does her best
uh-huh she does her best she's a good
dog actually I'm pretty sure I'm pretty
sure the subarray would hate my mom and
I'm opening up a whole can of worms
there by animalistic ly gathering all of
you guys cuz I'm declaring this
subreddit hates my mom again is not
about attacking any anyone here you
don't want to be you don't want to be
attacking anybody just because they
believe something differently that is
not what we're here for
true enough Matt Walsh I don't
understand people who say we don't
deserve dogs we wait on their hands and
foot we feed them walk them clean up
their poop if any side is failing to
carry their weight in the relationship
it isn't the human side that is a
[ __ ] lie the one thing that makes
feeding them waiting on them walking
them cleaning up their poop all so worth
it and you're acting like that's just
like 90% of the day it
makes me what like 15 minutes to walk my
dog which is a pleasant walk for me it
takes me another minute to pick up their
poof another two minutes to scoop their
food and water that's all it takes
that's what a few minutes out of my day
I walk a few times a day one in the
morning one in the evening two walks a
day thirty minutes and some time to feed
but all that aside all the waiting on
dog's hand and foot the one benefit of
what causes it to be not a one-sided
relationship is the amount of love that
that dog gives to me and you can debate
for years about oh is it really love I
don't care I get the privilege of being
around chica every day of my life
I get the privilege and the honor of
being around Henry every day of my life
I get the privilege of having that
companion by my side so loyal unshakable
faith in me as a person that is
inspiring every single day you cannot
pay for that you cannot give time for
that you cannot get that anywhere else
but with a pet that loves you that much
and just for me that is a dog that's my
dog
that's chica pica
100% you could begin I'll clean up or
poof I'll clean up her poop with my bare
hands I don't give a [ __ ] so long as I
get one more day with that dog I would
trade anything
you used to Maul me on that's really
funny but horrible it seems like a lot
of their grievances come from poorly
trained dogs and bad dogs in general
because just like there are shitty
humans there are shitty dogs that is a
fact there's no denying that there are
some shitty shitty dogs that are either
poorly trained or their behavior is just
completely wrong and that's no good at
all and totally understandable that does
not mean that that is the norm if there
seems to be a lot of misconception on
the sub right that this is somehow the
norm of what dog behavior is dog
behavior is not like this across the
board they're armed the majority of
people with dogs that are good dog
owners there are some shitty dog owners
too just like there are shitty parents
there are shitty dog owners and when I
say shitty I mean there are some shitty
dog owners I've encountered them myself
I think that they're bad to owning dogs
there I think they give a bad reputation
to owning dogs in general but that
doesn't mean that across the board you
can just make blanket sweep statements
because there are some pit bulls out
there or American Staffordshire which of
their actual name is and some of those
dogs are the sweetest dogs I've ever
known in my entire life
so back the [ __ ] off tumblr poses a good
question why are dog lovers so hateful
like you meet a cat lover and they're
like oh I love dogs a lot too I just
prefer cats but dog lovers are always
like my entire family was murdered by a
cat a cat stole my girlfriend
burned my house down took my job and
keyed on my car that last one isn't as
bad as the other ones there that's it's
like keying the cars not that bad
comparatively I mean it's bad but not
that
I have got no problem with cats I know I
don't think that many dog owners have
that problem with cats I think it's just
like a playful banter between cat owners
and dog owners like this isn't really
something that you can use fuel for it
because then you open up the can of orbs
with cats do you hate cats
does this subreddit hate cats is there a
cat's free oh god is there a cat free oh
no you know that's weird
there isn't a subreddit called cat free
hmm that's odd anyone else sick of
having half of the front page of Reddit
pictures of dogs like come on I get it
if there's one or two pictures a day but
every day it's a guarantee there will be
at least 10 post making to the front
page about dogs I want to get informed
and if find interesting threats not to
be reminded of how perfect your dog oh
is all right let's go to the front page
of Reddit shot when you see a dog cat
[Music]
there we go
dog Rufus is a good bull so the first
one was was a was a video game dog of
Rufus who very obviously is a good boy
that is a good boy Rufus is indeed a
good boy and that was all the way up
here now I'm not saying this is all the
time because I've gone to the front page
of Reddit and I've seen dogs before but
you know what happens when I do I smile
because it's a cute dog I wouldn't be
surprised to someone posted a cute baby
and it got up to the top but it just so
happens there's a lot of people that
like dogs they like seeing dogs when I
see my dog's face that adds years to my
life scientifically proven that adds
years to my life I'm gonna live longer
because I got that dog anyway there's
some ugly dogs out there but even the
ugly ones are cute even the ugly ones
are cute
thank you Wegmans no animals allowed
except service animals means certified
dogs or miniature horses so I want to
know what what what's allowing miniature
horses in grocery stores because that's
amazing but also this is not new this is
fine I have no problem with this no
animals except service animals and I
have a big problem with people buying
service animal harnesses for their dog
when they are
very clearly not a service animal that's
not okay very not okay service animals
are a special breed of dogs and/or other
animals that give great care and provide
a service to help their owner that is
very important and they must be with
them all the time and they are
incredibly well trained to be
specifically for those tasks of which
they are required this I have no problem
with I don't want dogs crawling around
the grocery store either if they don't
need to be there because yeah their paws
are a little dirty yeah I don't want him
getting all over the food that's no good
I don't want them breathing on the food
I don't want them looking the food
that's no good at all I'm okay with this
this is fine doesn't mean I hate dogs
when you upvote every non dog on our aw
and downvote every dog I'm doing my part
this isn't even the gift of this I can
barely read that I've got this zoomed in
and that's still blurry up during Murr
Burt okay I'm just judging you on the
fact that you can't get up good image
for this so I guess I've got no argument
here now this is disgusting two dead
horses you have killed two horses here
by throwing your dog poo bags over the
hedge into this field the first horse
died of a couple months back and the
autopsy showed her full of poop bags
the second died last week and the vet
said it was probably the same thing
horses are attracted to the smell of the
cereal content of dog poo now a full has
been left without his mother because you
couldn't be bothered to take the poo bag
home or put it in a bin now this is bad
this is bad I am against bad dog owners
I don't get how hard it is to pick up
after your dog I carry dog poop bags
wherever I go my dog poops I pick it up
it's that easy if you don't like it
don't have a dog that's just the same
see there is common ground here there is
common ground here I don't think that
everybody should have a dog because I
don't think that everybody should be
responsible enough for the ownership of
a dog that's fine however the very next
post
pitbulls for the win when you hear a
strange sound or someone moves too
quickly so you I'm sorry I shouldn't be
laughing at that
[Music]
so this is not this is not helpful this
is not helpful not helpful at all dogs
is this offspring married Millennials
the answer is no fair enough
I want to start yoga start by bending
over and picking up your dog [ __ ] known
as the downward dog position then put it
in a bin very good I like it haha
excellent
I love it basically this entire sub in a
nutshell I don't really like dogs to be
honest and that's an unpopular ass
opinion if ever there was one
like I love animals but dogs kind of
suck they're overrated as hell choke you
gotta you gotta understand it's not cool
but that's funny that is really funny
it's not cool just to spray hate on
someone for not liking someone and
that's what I want to make sure is very
clear about this subreddit it's fine to
not like dogs I don't care if you don't
like dogs that's fine not everyone is a
dog person how in is the ever you you
gotta know what you're getting yourself
into there are some people whose only
source of joy in life much like the
first post at the very top some people
whose only joy in life comes from the
dogs that they have that is their only
source of joy that is the one true
source of companionship that they have
I'm not saying that's a healthy thing
I'm not saying that's healthy at all but
understand if you attack the one thing
that that person loves more than
anything else in the world they are
going to attack you think that pitbulls
going after kids you should see a dog
mom come after no that's unhealthy but
it's just like everything in moderation
I hate to compare this to heroin or
something you know something that you
should have in moderation you know just
a little bit of heroin to even out the
day I hate to compare this to something
like sugar it's better sugar not heroin
sugar or cocaine or marijuana like but
everything in moderation like you gotta
be you gotta have things responsibly you
gotta have a dog responsibility you got
to take care of a dog you gotta you
gotta work through the dogs problems you
gotta train the dog you got to spend
time training the dog
you gotta spend time with the dog to
know what the dogs going to do you have
to understand the dog to know its
behaviors in different situations you
have to introduce it to new things and
see how that dog is going to train or
respond to it and then train it
accordingly of what it needs to do a dog
is a blank slate much like a child you
wouldn't just let a child roam free
without any education or training in any
way shape or form that child is going to
turn out to be a [ __ ] child which we
know occurs gratuitously
in society today and that's just comes
down to parenting and ownership not
parenting for the kids ownership for the
dogs not ownership for the kids and
parenting for the dog
very clear very distinct lines going on
here I also accidentally took the best
photo of my puppy oh god that's
hilarious okay this this picture right
here this is my mom but imagine my mom
is being slightly shorter than this man
here and this dog being twice the size
and that's because the only way to walk
Lucy is with both hands and both feet
firmly planted even me Lucy it's just
like this but knowing Lucy cuz we know
Lucy and we worked on Lucy I have not
worked on Lucy's behavior I wish I could
but because my mom has worked on Lucy
behavior my mom knows yeah better stay
away from this dog not that she's
dangerous in any way but this dog is
powerful this dog is excitable this is
not the type of dog that you would just
come up casually and say hi to and this
is not the dog that you take your eyes
off for a single second my mom knows
this my mom is a responsible dog owner
for that dog because that dog is a
specific type of dog that needs a
specific type of care the other little
dogs that he has little yuppie bastards
those those are fine this one's called
what the hell is wrong with some folks
[Music]
[ __ ] all right I think we can all agree
okay if everyone this uh bird is just
trying to single out that specific type
of dog owner then I think we're all on
board that's that is not right
am I right or what hard to swallow pills
showing me a picture of your [ __ ] bull
laying around with your baby doesn't
mean it couldn't snap at any moment and
rip that arms and legs off why do you
think that pit bulls or American
Staffordshire's are just these ticking
time bombs every one of them a ticking
time bomb can't be stopped with hoping
the sand the dog in its mind is just
like is a leg of a baby or a tasty like
a baby I wanna back up everybody hold on
back up back up back up back up back up
here back up here right now listen to me
don't go to the subreddit I'm very
serious about this don't go to the
subreddit don't stir up [ __ ] don't
confront people just because they don't
like dogs that's not the point of this
video the point of this video is to say
there is a right way to go about not
liking dogs because there are some
people that don't like dogs and that's
fine it's not a problem that you don't
like dogs
I adore owner don't have a problem if
you don't like dogs that's fine
I don't like people that are
irresponsible dog owners I don't like
bad dogs I don't like people that push
their dog in everybody's faces even if
I'm one of those people sometimes but
what I do want to put across here is
there is a wrong way to dislike dogs
just spouting hate for the sake of hate
lumping all dogs into a category lumping
all owners into a category that's not an
appropriate way to hate that's not good
dialogue you're not practicing what
you're preaching no one's gonna come
here and debate you anything because
you're obviously not trying to debate
anything you're trying to entrench her
in that all dogs are bad which they
aren't dogs are wonderful when they're
properly trained when they're properly
cared for when they're properly given to
the right family when the right owner
comes along for a dog that relationship
is beautiful that relationship is
fulfilling that relationship is awesome
that relationship provides like things
both ways
it may not be one-sided it absolutely
may not I have to provide for this
entire creature for the rest of its
natural life and I'm fine with that
because the companionship that that dog
gives me is totally worth it for me that
doesn't mean it's totally worth it for
anybody but for me that's a no-brainer
I would give anything for chica I would
go to the ends of the earth for that dog
because I make that choice and if people
don't want to make that choice that's
fine too I don't care doesn't affect me
at all but as soon as you get in my face
and tell me that I'm a bad person for
owning a dog then we have a problem so
let's just leave it at that sound good
so I'm not gonna link this subreddit in
the description because I am NOT trying
to stir [ __ ] up here and I again and
clickbait title may it be or not I just
wanted to make a video and look at your
funny memes because some of them just
really really for some weird reason some
of them really do make me laugh and I
don't know what that says about me but
this these these these ones are quite
funny I'm gonna look up sawing pictures
of your ugly [ __ ] bowl is not going to
change anyone's mind okay those dogs
[ __ ] beautiful those are amazing I
love every one of those those are such
good dogs I love them forever
[Laughter]
I'm the problem here I love that dog so
cute
I love that dog red in the face cuz I
love that dog so much okay yeah Nina
calm down here I've got too much love in
my face for that dog that dog is
horrible but also I love it so sweet so
gentle okay I'm done okay I'm done I'm
done
I could browse memes all day but I'm not
going to so all I'm saying right now is
there's a right way and there's a wrong
way
there's trying to paint something as
something it's not
and then there's looking at it
objectively from a truthful standpoint
this with this subreddit doesn't do it
doesn't look at anything from an
objective standpoint it tries to find
people that are like-minded and then
entrench further by going to extremes of
what the truth really is but at the same
time like I said it's okay to not like
dogs it's okay to never have a dog in
your entire life it's okay to want to be
as far away from dogs as possible that's
fine just don't be a dick about it
that's my general rule about life just
don't be a dick so that's all for this
video thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
in the comments below maybe you've got
an opinion about this maybe you've got a
dog that you love I've got a dog that I
love so what I'm gonna do after this
video is I'm gonna go pet that dog in
fact the end of this video is just going
to be a video of me petting my dog
because that's what I like so I'm gonna
do that so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I'll see you
in the next video
[Laughter]
[Music]